how's it going rose my spirit back
something has changed can you smell it
tastes like chicken
so recently there's been a lot of videos
regarding YouTube culture and that since
it's practically YouTube culture to do
whatever the everyone else is doing
I thought this was a great idea to have
a chat with you bros I think that the
main thing around the whole thing the
main thing around the whole thing
how's it goin is this whole YouTube
culture thing usually mainly revolves
around the relationship between the
youtuber and the fans and I remember
when I started making videos I didn't
even want to call you fans because it
seems so self-absorbed that I have fans
just because you watch my videos so
that's one of the reason why I wanted to
give you Bros name because to me it
feels like we're more the same that way
but also back then it was a lot easier
for me to talk to you bros I could
literally answer every messages I got
and I still try to answer as many
messages as I can but I notice it on
Twitter when I tweet something and
everyone is like come on tweet me tweet
me and I'm I feel like I have all this
hungry mouths to feed even even me
tweeting like another youtuber that
isn't as big as me well that one is oh
so I see fans going to that person and
tweeting him or her or saying like oh
you're so lucky that you got a tweet
from PewDiePie and it's like ah no don't
don't be doing that don't do that so
here's the point of all this I am NOT
above anyone not you now the other
youtubers not George Clinton white and
not anyone I'm the same as you so just
try and picture me as a bro like someone
who likes beautifies videos don't see me
as some higher entity or some
amazing thing or like I see people
saying oh you're so perfect but it's
like I know but really I'm not and
because no one who's perfect would say
like that I'm just like you bros I
and I hate to have you think that I'm
above anyone cuz I'm really not and I
don't want you to thinking that and um I
feel like this is partially my fault
because I could be more responding
better to you bros and stuff like that
so I wanted to address it in the video
and just say that but when I started
making videos on YouTube I had a very
very tiny following ain't nobody gave a
about me all right when I stopped
making videos anybody's gonna give a
about me too
so really youtubers we're not that
special most of us are just really weird
people that find something to be nerdy
with and apparently that puts us in a
high position on the Sun and over other
people and it shouldn't be like that
it's it's dumb I'm sorry if I ramble a
lot this video bros if you skipped to
the ending hi what the are you
doing I'm skating um to summarize I love
you bros
don't take this in the wrong way I just
want to make it clear that we are
equally awesome okay how about that so
I'll I'll try better to break the wall
between us
because that's that I love the close
connection that I have with you bros
that's what makes it YouTube fun with me
so seeing all these things on Twitter
and Facebook and all these stuffs that
it worries me a little bit it's kind of
crazy so let's just take down on match
poor like yet nerd or so strife as
Vanessa gone for free and I'm a
PewDiePie oh and yeah blah blah face
poeira
i laying dude